hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to corpse party now I
couldn't find anything else in this room
wait maybe I didn't I don't think I
check these walls nope I don't think
there's anything else here so let's just
keep moving on hey there's something
over here said Satoshi exclamation Li oh
is that a dead body is that the dead
body that I need to find in this river
of blood dun dun dun dun
I love that so cliche but somehow I love
it hello dead party can I pick you up
and we're gonna take you and bury you is
that the ghost body I need to be careful
because I'm being a little bit too loud
on my voice I need to make sure it lasts
a little bit cuz we got a lot to record
I think so
yeah I think we got a barrier yeah don't
suppose you brought a shovel with you
actually cuz I'm gonna be closer than
Mike let me just move this camera down a
little bit thank you
don't suppose you brought a shovel with
you I believe we should cremate her and
the incinerator [ __ ] we can figure
something out later for now let's just
take her body well who's gonna stuff
that into their backpack I think we're
gonna have to dismember a getaway don't
touch me okay
don't did you think you were doing me a
favor did you think I was lonely you
don't know anything I can never cross
over you ignorant worms we know we all
know your sad story you told us the
other you me the other me
the me that bears my other conscience
your sorrow your pain your bitterness I
can understand it a little dot dot dot
there is a time in our lives where we
all will eventually lose someone
precious to us I can understand that dot
dot but there's a reason and there's no
reason in making any more victims like
you right shinozaki I'm sorry I'm so
hello lady in red shall we head back I
don't think it's gonna be this easy yes
I got a bad feeling about this
where do you think you're going oh you
all have not suffered nearly enough oh
you think you can fix me arrogant filth
oh oh my goodness you shall see the evil
that will truly lurks within I knew it
couldn't be this easy
I will kill you oh that's bad I will
butcher you you like sheep big brother
I'm scared you can say close you can
hear that girl's consciousness I'm sorry
I can't control her at all please run I
can't do anything yes sir
hurry die I must kill you get away it's
a fire dead Oh split-personality going
on here I love it it's no running only
death I'll tear you apart that's not
good please choose your character for
battle it's actually battle you must
have at least two characters to battle
the vengeful spirit will see our
finished head to the north exit to
commence the battle you gain powers from
the girls spirit earlier everyone gain
different powers for a detailed
explanation of all their newfound
abilities touch the lower right desk
ok cool yes I do
those Satoshi si attack power speed is
lacking one also has no magic main magic
user in the group has such a high MP
she's a healer the group despite being
able to use restorative magazine COO and
he inspires the buffer of the group is
skill II will increase the attitudes of
his fans priest of the group she can
resurrect those who hit HB hit zero
I can only pick two well I don't a buff
if there's now many people to buff I
think it what Satoshi because the high
attack power if I have Satoshi and the
healer then it should work out well
because I don't need magic if um oh I
might need magic in general the main guy
a magic user any healer okay I save
I'm gonna save Jesus of course I'm gonna
save I have no idea what I'm doing
no player eyeball
can I pick anymore could it please beg
some more
can I pick more oh I can't pick three
okay cool
awesome awesome awesome awesome I would
have gone with two I would have been a
very big mistake so he gave you powers
you think you get it as be powerful okay
so main guys Satoshi you're obviously
the damage dealer so you're gonna use
your magic and you're gonna use psychic
surge and vengeful spirit and you're
gonna just defend you're gonna save up
your stuff and defend cuz I don't need
you dying wow that hurt a lot
74 damage that's a wish you could see
your health
Mookie's ooh tank attack heal all allied
with a comforting aura
no [ __ ] well that's stupid
oh well this was a stupid waste of time
everybody okay this may take a while
just bear with me
hey okay I just had to use a kind of a
thing where I was able to enhance the
guy's strengths so much that he became
so powerful that he was just able to
wipe him out and then if I defended
against one of the attacks of the off
everyone hitting oh look thank you this
is possibly the end of the game that
can't be I sold this game was much
longer than that I sold this game was
incredibly long wait a minute what's
going on here
crap the school we run we're trapped
down here shut up I hear something
everybody shut up I'm concentrating a
school bell chimed loudly why well huh
you hear the voice of the girls spirit
everyone hurry they're trying to use
forbidden magic they're gonna use you
all as a sacrifice who forbidden that
doesn't sound good
this school relies on my spiritual
powers with that diminishing the spirits
are looking for a new source to sustain
themselves forgive me it was all my
fault well what should we do
this place is going under but where do
we run run a classroom to nine that's
the closest place to your own world when
the bell rings ten times their ceremony
will be completed so over here that nine
times you must hurry this should all be
a wall you can destroy inside this room
I imagine I know where it is come on let
me do Flemmi attic stop being douches go
go go go get it walls smeared I know
okay just let me at it I know that's it
it's got to be a wall I can destroy
oh come on I want to continue the
cultural festival okay whatever
ha but cement Oh bong come on I know I
know time is rung two times it's great
yeah that's great good
hey this is it hey guys I found it go go
go go go come on come on come on hurry
hurry hurry
hey I don't know which way to go not
that way
bong I know come on what kind of crazy
school is this just let me go home
you crazy sons of [ __ ] get me out of
here I gotta go go go go go go go go go
go I don't even know go the right way
but I did apparently good good good good
good
goo do go run run run run like about
okay oh no no no ball I get it good get
it come on come on come on I know
let me save alone where's the rest of my
party we're all the evil spirits
sister what the hell is going on okay I
get it no no no no no no no no no no
don't be a douche I don't have time to
talk to you
I got a crisis situation going on here
okay oh god damn it what was i doing I'm
such an idiot
come on why do I have to stop every time
it chimes let me know that was all
scripted wasn't it such a son of a [ __ ]
oh this is qu9 it's shining do we have
to jump into it we would be okay you
hear that girl's voice you made it in
time I did now getting it under the
light don't turn away take heat in my
advice do not turn around no matter what
why you turn away the light will
disintegrate your body so whatever you
do don't turn away what this is the baby
sense okay don't do it away wait a
minute what happens if I turn away I
can't you near that girl's voice wait
that's not the right way if you go that
way you'll fall on top to back that way
dobby kirk and all their barking well
now stupid well then all right then we
did good everybody thanks I'll be right
back
really this is what you're gonna do with
your life
really you [ __ ] really
you son of a [ __ ] just let me go ah
come on
what is that [ __ ] why did it do that
then oh come on
Oh God suddenly he like nothing Oh God
okay all their heads exploded oh why you
didn't let me go anywhere why I'm not
running cuz apparently running is bad
for the timing it messes everything up
and I'm not supposed to run in the
hallways just a general rule the school
I'm not gonna run not gonna panic I'm
not gonna go quickly cuz barely I'd told
me to go quickly
hello I don't make up the rules so how
about you go ahead yourself cool don't
dick quiz me right now no don't do not
let me up those tears don't explode my
head if you explode my head I will be
very angry new son of a [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
what what what what the hell with the
bullets with the bull honking hell what
is this hell bull Oh am I here now
what did I make it this time oh okay you
know what I whatever you know she's
whatever whatever I can hear that girl's
voice don't turn back whatever just go
okay
that was not worth my time everybody not
worth my time
don't turn away okay whatever I'm just
going going going why can't I what Oh
what happened huh
Oh Oh what why are they
no what no I'm not I'm not turning back
I don't know what you're talking about
what's going on okay oh I was still
moving forward okay I didn't think it
was actually going anywhere can't move
don't know why but something strange is
happening am i still moving forward
can't interact with it just gonna keep
going still going forward not turning
around I don't give me phone I'm in the
middle of something I am very busy with
not turning around no matter what I
ain't cornu none ah okay
all right cool cool cool cool cool cool
cool okay all right cool
all right cool all right cool cool cool
cool cool cool well who am i back dr.
tot hello every body is hardly be doing
here I'll be back home I don't think
it'll be that easy
oh we're back our class is a classroom
no way we made it we made it back alive
oh hey weird cheering noise am I still
not supposed to turn back I'm not gonna
turn back I'm still moving forward
Camus II don't know what's happening big
bro
yuca ee let's go home I'm beat
I totally agree man I can't get over how
late it is
he y'all seem very cheerful I would be
hesitant to believe that it is over what
about that whole spiritual thing with
the circle and so we made it back home
whoo I glanced over my shoulder taking
account of you canõt me she knows a key
and Yoshiki thank God we're all alive
safe and sound I don't think so because
there was a whole thing everyone was
thinking the same thing
thank God we're free but we dare not
jinx ourselves I forgot something I'll
just be a sec oh oh
hey stupid go after her yeah yeah
Satoshi did you find it
yeah come on let's go home my parents
must be worried sick that girl she must
have been suffering for decades before
we were even born all alone in that
awful place I feel so sorry for her it's
alright we saved her you know
we solved terrible things too but we
still rose to the challenge so
everything's okay now isn't it
yeah you're right right let's go home if
it is that easy
Satoshi what's wrong Naomi this isn't
like you
Satoshi do you see me as a woman oh yes
oh that's not the answer I gave ya what
am I saying this isn't like me at all it
must seem so weird dr. dot dr. Todd hey
would you would you like to come over
and listen to me play the piano sure I'd
love to okay cool Bing bong Bing bong
the schoolhouse was completely silent
It was as if what we just went through
never happened I guess life will just
continue as normal from here on out
right
after all there's no evidence of our
misery no proof of what happened how the
heck did you find that ghost story
anyway
perhaps the spirit or self spreaded man
that's a scarier thought than any ghost
story
corpse party or what that's it no way
they look happy it was that playing the
right game here I have no idea what's
happening then no no it can't be it
that can't be the end of the game
something's not right here
something don't feel quite right what's
happening here what's going on here
wait a minute what's going on here why
are they still down there what's going
on there in that dream world it's gonna
something's not right
Oh who's that happening so know what's
happening close buddy going on I'm very
confused
ending rank a I did good my sure I want
to quit no no no no no I like to enter
saundra mode no no no no yeah okay now
what can't be it
congratulations a big bar is there's
still much more to see different events
past roots and triggers this is a place
where you listen to the games BMG's he's
got a lot serious spacely's baby yeah
mom who's kidding enjoy listening well
alright then
um don't know what's going on here
because I seem to recall I thought this
was a much longer series now I didn't
see anything else about this game so I
have no idea if I'm in the right place
or not but I saw other people's
playthroughs of this game like cries was
like a twenty seven part series and I'm
done I think play the totally wrong game
was happening was it going good but
apparently I beat it so I have no idea I
got no idea I'm so confused so there you
have it
against that was corpse party the
original game rebuilt now I think there
was another one that was can't be right
guys I don't know I honestly don't know
this game was really fun it was a great
story
it was less the scares than I thought
there'd be but still it was a very
creepy atmosphere and a very good I
can't shake the feeling that I'm doing
something very wrong here but either way
this game was still fun and this is all
I got to chance to pre-record so I like
I recorded all this and I don't know
what's going on I'm gonna try to find
out what's going on here and I thought
there was more to this obviously I went
a certain path and there were different
triggers and there's different stuff I
could have done but apparently I got an
a-rank ending so let me know in the
comments below once again I am NOT here
I am in New York when you're seeing this
so I'm not able to change anything if
you think I did something wrong but
either way this is it for now when I get
back I'm gonna definitely explore this
more so thanks again everybody for
watching click the annotations and check
the description for more RPG horror
games that I played in the past there
are a lot of fun there's a whole bunch
of them and I'm definitely gonna keep
looking into this because something
ain't right here not me right so anyway
thank you all again for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video